el veterano izquierdista de jean luc
mélenchon se ha convertido en el rostro
de la política progresista francesa el
político de la izquierda se quedó por
muy poco por fuera de la ronda final de
las elecciones presidenciales del 2022
era uno de los seis candidatos de
izquierdas incluidos los verdes los
comunistas y los una vez poderosos
socialistas en total menos de un tercio
de los franceses votaron por un
progresista después de los resultados
los seguidores de m link son culparon a
los otros partidos de quitarles valiosos
votos a su candidato a pesar de ello
insisten en que la lucha está lejos de
terminar
debido a los franceses que me elijan
como su primer ministro votan una
mayoría de diputados del partido de
francia insumisa de nuestro grupo unión
popular hay una tercera vuelta por venir
en una segunda vuelta sino también una
tercera
bolt la tercera ronda a la que se
refiere mi lección son las elecciones
parlamentarias de junio su partido franz
insumisa ha llamado a los políticos de
unirse a una coalición de izquierdas de
este modo espera ganar suficientes
escaños en la asamblea nacional para
reforzar un gobierno de cohabitación con
el poder el último gobierno de
cohabitación en francia se remonta a
1997 jacques chirac tuvo que trabajar
por el primer ministro socialista lionel
jospin el propio mel en jong fue
ministro subalterno en ese gobierno en
representación del ala de la izquierda
del partido socialista pero en el 2008
renunció a su familia política para
crear un movimiento más radical que ha
ido creciendo desde entonces a pesar de
la elección del socialista françois
hollande en 2012 el partido seguía
dividido entre los defensores de un
programa de izquierdas partidarios de
reformas laborales favorables para las
empresas
la marca ha sido dañada no son sólo los
votantes de la clase trabajadora
el hombre que veo lance eligió para
ayudarle con algunas de las reformas más
controvertidas fue manuel macro el joven
ministro crearía más tarde su propio
partido centrista en el 2017 se presentó
con éxito a las elecciones arrasando con
gran parte del voto socialdemócrata
desde entonces los socialistas han sido
superados por macrón en la derecha y
elección en la izquierda llegando a un
mínimo histórico de menos del 2% el 10
de abril en las próximas semanas se verá
si los partidos de la izquierda
fracturados pueden dejar de lado sus
diferencias y unirse
[Música]